okay, now let's look at
How we can go from conditional probability?
To the Bayesian theorem. Now there's a lot of mathematical expression
as you can see here, but we'll take it one step at
a time.
So we are going to go from conditional probability to the Bayesian
theorem.
Now what you need to know is that there are different ways you can express.
the Basin theorem
Let's see how we can derive the Bayesian theorem from from conditional probability.
So here we are told that the
probability of a given B.
Is equal to this is this expression?
The probability of BNA over the probability of B.
had we
swapped
BNA
or rather had we swapped in B with BNA we would have gotten
a similar
expression on the right
And sit in the denominator the instead in the denominator,
we would have had.
A instead of B.
The numerator is obviously are equivalent.
When you performed the intersection of two sets.
It is commutative. So the order doesn't matter.
But let's talk about equation one.
if we take
probability of B
and multiply
in both sides
So probability of B here and here.
Probability of B would be canceled out.
From the denominator and it will appear here.
on the left
so we would get this.
equation
Okay, as you can see probability of
B has moved from the denominator.
Over here to the left.
Had we done the same thing.
for equation 2 where we canceled or
where we multiply the probability of a
on both sides of the equation
We would have gotten.
this
so probability of a has moved from the
denominator.
Here to the left.
Now, please click close attention to these two equations
equations, three and four.
it might be a good idea for you to
Pause here. And then
Go back to the start of the video. Make sure you've seen what
we've done so far. All we've done is Multiplied
both sides of the equation.
With the marginal probability to move from the right to the left to Move
It from the denominator to the left.
but anyway
We said that these two.
Can be moved around?
Intersection is a commutative probability is
a commutative operation. So whether
we say probability of BNA
or the probability of A and B is the same
thing.
in other words
equation 1
excuse me equation 3
is equivalent to equation 4.
and if the equations are well equal to
one another not a
if the equations are equal to one another
then the terms on each side
of the equal sides are also equivalent.
So
if probability of B and A.
Is equal to that?
And we said that intersection is commutative, which means this.
Is also equal to that.
And we can see that probability of A and B is equal to that.
That means the probability of BNA.
is equal
to that
and if I remove these two expressions here
in the middle, we will get this.
They are equivalent.
If we were to divide.
both sides of the equation
With the probability of B.
that it would have
then we would have equation five b.
Right. We move probability of B to the
other side.
It's now the denominator.
but
up here an equation 5
we set that the probability of B and the probability
of B given a times probably of B is equivalent to
the probability of a given B
times the probability of B.
So another way to write this.
is that
These two are equivalent.
Okay.
Again, it's a good idea for you to maybe write this down.
And you work your way up to this point
before you continue.
Alright, let's move down. Let's move on.
The probability of B.
We can replace this marginal probability
with the sum of joint probabilities.
If you remember from the example where we had the table
of frequencies.
and the marginals
we saw that the probability of B.
was the sum of its intersection with
a
and the interest and within the intersection of the complement of
To refresh your memory. Let me pull up that example.
this example
probability of BNA
will give you five probability of B and not
a or the complement of a also 5.
add these up and you will get
the sum
which is equal to the marginal probability.
Okay. So again.
The probability of B.
is equal to
the sum of these joint probabilities
This is true.
No matter what the events are.
now
probably of BNA for bring your attention
here.
We said that this is equivalent to
up here
We said that this is equivalent to this expression.
Yes.
We said that.
the probability of b and a is equal to
the probability of B and the probability of b and a
is equal to this expression.
But we also said that this expression.
Is equal to that expression?
And so we can substitute.
The probability of B and A.
with
this expression by equivalence
By equivalence we can replace this.
with that
similarly
We can replace this.
with a similar looking expression except here instead of
a we have to complement a
And this is what?
We are going to use.
We're going to use this form of the
Bayesian theorem at the next example.
Now this is the probability version.
There is also a likelihood version of The Basin theorem.
But that's for the next section.
But it's important for you to see that.
the busy theorem looks
simple
but it
requires this axiomatic thinking to understand how
we could go from conditional probability to different.
Algebraic arrangements and even the Bayesian
theorem can take on different forms, which is why if we were to
look up PC and Theorem online.
You would see that this formula is expressed in
different ways.
And that is because of equivalence.
We can do so.
It will be a good idea.
For you to try to do this yourself as well as an exercise.
Go from conditional probability.
to the Bayesian theorem